in this opening faculty roundtable
entitled race and the transformation of
disciplines
we are extremely fortunate to have five
terrific scholars
who will share their perspectives on
these issues
each will offer approximately five
minutes of opening comments
which will be followed by a brief intra
panel discussion
and then we will have the remainder of
our time to take your questions
i'm going to now offer a very brief
introduction to each of our speakers
in the order in which they will speak
and you should know that in the chat we
also have links to their full bios
if you are interested in having that
information
at this point we're thrilled to have
our first speaker will be rod ferguson
who's a professor of women's gender and
sexuality studies and american studies
at yale university ferguson's research
and teaching
interests include the politics of
culture women of color feminism
the study of race critical university
studies queer social movements and
social theory
matthew terrell is professor of africana
studies and american studies and the
chair of american studies at brown
he's a history historian of race and
nation with a focus on the us
from the civil war to the present marcy
kwan
is an assistant professor of art and art
history at stanford university
her research and teaching interests
include the intersection of fine art and
vernacular practice
theories of modernism cultural exchange
between asia and the americas
folk and self-taught art and issues of
race and object hood
noemi diami is an assistant professor of
english at the university of chicago
her research and teaching explores the
relationship between
theater understood simultaneously as a
medium
a practice an industry an institution a
social force and a vibrant
malleable set of literary forms and the
social political
cultural struggles of early modernity
and finally we will hear from teresa
montoya who is the provost's
postdoctoral fellow
and in 2022 will be an assistant
professor of anthropology
at the university of chicago she's a
social scientist and media maker
trained in sociocultural anthropology
critical indigenous studies and
filmmaking
please join me in welcoming virtually uh
our panelists and we will now hear from
rod ferguson thank you
all right well thanks so much um it's a
pleasure to be here
i'm going to set my watch for five
minutes so that i don't go over
um you know for me
the question of uh the racial reckoning
with the disciplines begins with
um the question of the reorganization of
knowledge
one and its relationship to
uh the
cultivation of underrepresented
and new communities of subjects within
the university
um within and also outside of the
discipline and i'll say more about that
a bit later but um this was something
that was driven home
for me when i was a grad student at uc
san diego
uh being advised by george lipsitz
and lisa lowe there was something about
that moment in which
things clicked for me that the work that
we were doing
was not simply a textual exercise right
that it had institutional um
and epistemological implications things
were supposed to shift
um that the work in fact the work that
we were doing
in our dissertations for the professors
and
their books it was to announce both
epistemic shifts
and also institutional shifts
within fields
on campuses in terms of faculty
and also in terms of students and so
that was a profound
uh revelation for me that it wasn't
simply a kind of professional exercise
the study of race
and its impact on the disciplines um it
wasn't simply a kind of professional
exercise
that was used to satisfy certain
benchmarks in terms of
uh the awarding of a phd or
promotion that it was about
reorganizing the taken for granted
knowledges
uh within certain fields introducing
other forms of knowledge within those
fields and
also making space for
underrepresented uh
people new subjects new communities
um who would also take up
the question or the act of reckoning uh
and offer really new kinds of
innovations
uh at the level of scholarship
um there is a passage
uh in jacques derrida's
uh the eyes of the university that
kind of summed it up for me you know i'd
always had that sense again
from my time at uc san diego
the work that i was doing um you know
with my colleagues there the advising
that i was getting from people like
george
and lisa but it wasn't until you know i
encountered this
passage from derrida that i had language
for the
institutional and social importance of
the work that we were doing and so i'll
just read a bit from that
passage all right he says with students
in the research community
in every operation we pursue together a
reading
an interpretation the construction of a
theoretical model
the rhetoric of an argumentation the
treatment of historical material
and even a mathematical formalization we
posit or acknowledge that an
institutional concept
is at play a type of contract signed
an image of the ideal seminar
constructed associates
implied repeated or displaced invented
transformed threatened or destroyed and
institution is not
merely a few walls or some outer
structures
surrounding protecting guaranteeing or
restricting the freedom of our work
it is also and already the structure
of our interpretation and so part of
what
uh i find so useful about that is that
it gets at
the immediacy of um
the reckoning that the reckoning happens
at the moment
that we're thinking about the book we're
gonna write
the course we're gonna teach how we
frame those things
and that in those very immediate
and small acts we're actually trying
to either repeat
a discipline or
[Music]
you know displace disciplinary knowledge
in the name of alternative forms of
knowledge all right so i'll stop there
thank you i have spent much of the
pandemic thinking about a 40 year old
novel
octavia butler's kindred and i want to
talk a little bit about it
before i share my thoughts about the
humanities
published in 1979 the book tells the
story of a black woman named dana who's
suddenly
inexplicably and repeatedly transported
back to the antebellum south
to save her ancestor a white slave owner
named rufus
whenever rufus's life is threatened dana
is yanked backwards in time without
warning or control
her reappearances though keep rufus
alive and by extension
ensure her very existence and by the
novel's conclusion
dana is fundamentally changed by this
recursive experience
leaving us to wonder about causality and
inevitability
the world around her notably remains
just as disturbingly
uneven as it was at the start
dana is a hero for our pandemic
non-plussed by her time traveling
she's practical and level-headed
routinely confronts terror with
thoughtful planning
after her first dislocation she returns
home and has the forethought to
widely wisely assemble a bag of
necessary supplies
tying them to her waist she brings maps
and history books from the present into
the past
along with knives and painkillers soap
and toothpaste and clothing
like the author who created her dana is
defined by lists
and is the champion of organized
thinking in the face of calamity
this faith and relentless practicality
saves her life
the knife she brings back in time the
kind of weapon denied to any enslaved
person
the kind of weapon she knew she might
need is what she uses to kill rufus in
the novel's final pages
i've shared kindred more times than i
can count in the last
12 months my deepest hope has been that
the students who are now zooming into
our meetups from bedrooms kitchen tables
and patios
in almost every conceivable time zone
and who might feel
displaced buffeted and even scared can
find in dana's steely determination
a practical model for their own everyday
survival
there's a valuable lesson here for us
too as we ponder the relationship
between race and the humanities
all of dana's courage and imagination
inevitably leads her right back to the
present
there's no other timeline and no counter
factual reality
her movements back and forth from the
antebellum south to the modern present
change nothing in her world she gains
memories
a measure of herself and a sober
understanding of the realities of
slavery
but she loses something too after
rufus's death she materializes back in
present-day california
her arm painfully adjoined to the
timbers and nails and plaster of the
house
its removal sets her free but leaves her
without a limb
i really couldn't let her come all the
way back butler
once explained to randall kennan i
couldn't let her return to what she was
i couldn't let her come back whole
when i was first asked to consider the
idea of a racial reckoning
i returned once more to kindred a
reckoning i know
is a dramatic settlement of deaths it
can be a jarring event
a disruptive painful occurrence it
should cost
and who should bear that cost i thought
of field locked history departments and
english departments
unable to truly center racial justice in
their work
because of an old-fashioned commitment
to geographic or temporal divisions
that date back to jim crow to white
supremacy or to empire
i thought of entire disciplines classics
for instance or medieval studies
where the labor of decades is now the
foundation stone of white supremacy
i thought of the small interdisciplines
many of them zeroed in on race
all of them starved for resources
compared to their larger peers
and over-determined as the place where
race happens
or is or will be i thought of budget
models like
rcm which valorize student credit hours
over righteousness or social importance
i thought of all of this
and so much more and asked exactly what
sort of reckoning should there be
such questions come to me even as i am
overwhelmed
joyfully and ecstatically by the volume
of work in the humanities on race
i am drowning in books in podcasts
in graphic novels in think pieces in
documentaries
and in twitter threads surrounded at
home and at work
by disorganized piles alphabetical piles
thematic piles and color-coded piles
every single one of them evidence that
the dam has burst
that we are in some very perverse way
fortunate to be writing and thinking
through all of this
our own dystopia together with such a
vast and extraordinary assemblage of
people
authors of some of the best work ever
conceived
what would it mean to center this
everywhere how could that happen
and what would that cost the humanities
to paraphrase butler after a true
reckoning with our past and present
would we want to bring the university
all the way back
the humanities will someday have a
reckoning and that reckoning will i
think
tear these places apart and leave them
conceptually burning and broken
there's some promise in our prospective
losses
in what parts of these places might be
cut off
and we in this zoom should all be
planning for it
with knapsacks tied to our wastes filled
with old maps and history books
painkillers and knives and soaps and
toothpastes
thank you
hi everyone um thank you for having me
here today
i have a can't do anything without
images
so
so this year the cantor arts center
which is the university
art museum here at stanford um
launched the asian american art
initiative co-directed by myself and
elisa alexander
curator of american art the initiative
is dedicated
to the collection preservation research
and exhibition of work by asian american
and diaspora artists
who with the exception of a handful of
canonical figures remain almost entirely
unknown
in art history the dearth of interest
and support for asian american artists
within art history stands in direct
contrast to the historical importance
of the arts to asian americans
while researching the 2009 survey text
asian american art history
1850 to 1970 mark dean johnson who
actually worked on this project
as a fellow at csre and stanford
historian gordon chang
identified over 1 000 artists of asian
descent
working in california alone during this
chronological span
which is again 1850 to 1970.
so this number is staggering indicating
not only
the significance of art and art making
for asian americans
but also the enormous volume of work
that remains to be studied
and has likely been lost to time and
what you see on your screen is actually
um they're photographs from
maze photo studio which was a
chinese-run
photography studio in san francisco
chinatown
akin to james van der zee you know
photographing the community
um and these works were saved actually
from a dumpster
in the 1970s by the artist wiley wong
um what you see here are mac hats of
photographs that were actually
pieced together in the dark room um kind
of uniting families that were
um divided by
um america american legal like
exclusionary
um immigration policy
so we launched this year with a
collection that includes 151
historical works from the estate of a
private collector which were being held
in a storage locker in san rafael
um which you see on the screen on the
left
um we also receive donations from
foundations of artists such as martin
long and bernie spang
um whose work you see on the right it's
actually covered in plastic which is why
it looks like that
on the left is a painting from the brown
collection
by um the first documented japanese
american painter
um in the united states um
and we also acquired an untitled
wall of masks by the artist ruth asawa
who cast them
from the faces of visitors to her home
and they include people like anna duver
smith
we have also made it a priority to
ensure that we preserve
archival material from these artists
so asian american studies has helped me
think through the ethical dimensions of
this
project it is not lost on me that part
of art history's conservatism
has to do with its emphasis on physical
objects
objects that are bought and sold making
it more obviously entangled with market
forces than other academic disciplines
this has also made art history
especially reliant on institutions such
as museums to undertake the extensive
and
expensive conservation preservation and
display of works of art
and finally there's the problem of the
way that race and identity discourse are
mobilized by institutions as a means to
manage descend
um an issue that rod's work as well as
riley reilly's edited volume with hentai
gap has helped me think
through so we've tried to navigate these
ethical challenges in multiple ways
um in our discussions of the asian
american art initiative we always begin
with the fact that stanford is itself
unthinkable without the entwined
histories of chinese immigrant labor
imperialist expansion
and capitalism as manuka has
shown and in fact the golden last spike
and
the silver mallet used to hammer it into
place the joining of the
transcontinental railroad or at the
canter arts center
um recent archaeological work has also
revealed that
even the palm trees on palm drive were
planted by chinese laborers
so another goal of our work is to show
how historical research and deep formal
engagement with works of art
breaks rather than reinforces a
monolithic idea of asian america
um as a bounded identity forum as well
as its assumptions
of um a single nation state
and rather than keeping our work in the
feedback loop with the
academia the museum and the art world
we're trying to make sure that we engage
local communities
in part through education and public
programming
um and most importantly we know that our
efforts
cannot benefit just the community of
asian americans but all
racialized groups whose histories and
lives are entangled with ours
and i want to acknowledge that csre and
jen brody
in particular have been unfailingly
supportive of these efforts
so still i must admit that i have
serious reservations about how our work
will be used something that keeps me up
at night
um museums are of course colonial
institutions built on the hoarding of
property and increasingly reliant on the
commodification of people of color
all i can say is that i believe the work
of these artists have many things to
teach us
about the structures that have attempted
to circumscribe their existence
i can only imagine the things they will
teach us
about for example racial capitalism and
aesthetics the way quote
art has been historically tethered to
the idea of be human
and hierarchies of taste and value
our history should be the study of all
of these things
but also as ann cheng has pointed out
more than 20 years ago and
continues to remind us um
in the united states a person of color
is seen as worthy of attention only when
they have suffered visible harm
while asian american artists have never
been outside of history
they invite us to think and feel in ways
that
perhaps sidestep this obsession with
injury
their work shows us the multiple and
complex ways asian americans have lived
worked created desired and imagined in
relation to a world that seeks ever more
devious ways to homogenize and devalue
them
thank you
thank you hello everybody i am thrilled
to be here in the presence of such
brilliance
and i'm really excited to learn from
everybody today
i hope to contribute something to this
ongoing conversation by telling you a
little bit
about the current state of my field
early modern critical race studies
and telling you about its current state
through the lens of our key concept
racial reckonings so what do we do
early modern critical race scholars
examine the deployment
of racial formations in periods prior to
the development
of so-called scientific racism in the
18th century
starting in 1492 and we do so in various
cultural domains such as literature
performance religion visual culture
material culture and more
the word reckoning as was pointed out
earlier
is etymologically embedded in practices
of accounting
it's about numbers it's about counting
putting an order
calculating and including in that count
what must be
included and accounted for the pioneers
of my field had to counter the
convenient assumption
that there were no bipark people in
early modern europe
or differently put that shakespeare had
never seen a black person when he wrote
othello
quote unquote in order to make a case
for the importance of racial thinking in
early modern europe
we are indebted to the the subfield of
present studies
best illustrated by the pens-taking work
of the late india's habib
and his marvelous black lives in the
english archives
for some serious reckoning for the field
can only grow i'm sorry
for the field to grow reckoning in the
accountant sense applied and still
applies not only to the archives but to
those who read them
it has thus been imperative in our field
to reckon with the dismal numbers of
bypoc scholars in early modern studies
so most english curricula as you know
have a shakespeare requirement
but to the best of my knowledge there
are only currently
less than 20 tenutrak faculty members
who identify as black shakespeare
professors in the us at the moment we
also have
had and still have to start building
diverse pipelines
which is an ongoing struggle because by
poc students are conditioned or maybe
disciplined
from high school onwards into thinking
of the pre-modern periods
as irrelevant to their concerns of
course that's
that is a misconception we know that
stuart hall originally wanted to be a
medievalist
and that sylvia winter for instance was
primarily trained as a specialist
of early modern spanish drama
in short racial reckonings in my field
have been about changing both the
objects that we study
and the demographics of scholars who
study them
but of course the disciplinary field can
only be transformed if its theoretical
frameworks tools and questions are
transformed as well
early modern critical race studies
emerged historically
in the mid 90s when scholars like kim f
hall
brought theoretical frameworks drawn
from black feminism
and critical race theory to bear on
early modern materials
and to make early modern studies
accountable anjalumba around the same
time did the same with
frameworks drawn from postcolonial
feminism
a second wave of scholarship on race in
the ali martin period started in the
first decade of the 21st century
and we are now in the third or fourth
depending on how you count
a wave of scholarship in the field yet
valid concerns have been expressed by
field founders kim f hall and peter
erickson in 2016
in the 2016 special issue of shakespeare
quarterly focused on race
and they alerted us in that issue to the
risks of
dispersion to the very real risk that
the field
even as it starts receiving
institutional recognition in various
forms
might lose its political impetus and its
original concern
with racial justice to honor and to act
upon the activist drive that founded the
field
a research collaborative such as race
before race
which was founded by ayanna thompson and
um
nu chicago is a partner institution of
race before race
that collaborative has for the last
couple of years
advocated in various forms for the
centrality of critical race theory
to the field if you're curious to hear
more i encourage you to check the
webpage of race before race
our next symposium i'm sorry i have to
make a quick plug
our next symposium focused on politics
that's the theme
with the keynote by ibrahim candy opens
this coming tuesday
to return to my point racial reckoning
is about political accountability
which must be intentionally cultivated
at all times in my field
we were asked to think about the ways in
which we center
racial justice in our work and it is
perhaps
um for research the research part of our
work that the question is most urgent
an example might be useful at this point
in my most recent article
i'm making my work politically
accountable to the present
has meant that when i started noticing
slippages in 17th century plays which
depict
and label the same characters
alternately as
blackmores and romani gypsies
i had to think about those modern those
early modern slippages
through the lens of the many instances
today
when scholars working in the fledgling
field of critical romani studies
invoke paradigms from black studies in
pursuit of shared
liberation this led me to read the early
modern archive as providing an ethically
binding genealogy
for those critical alliances which are
reconstituting
now methodologically speaking doing such
work requires never forgetting about the
present as you analyze the past
developing some sort of double vision
moving to and fro between historic
historicization
and theorization racial reckonings also
transform disciplinary affects
to do this work you have to keep in mind
that the stakes of the work
as you know rod was pointing out earlier
um the stakes of the work which are so
real
they outweigh the playful dimension of
aesthetic exploration which is one of
the main appeals of literary studies
and you have to pay close attention to
the ways in which paranoid or reparative
leanings
might inform your own scholarship and
its reception
because those matter i will close by
saying that
working uh with theoretical bodies of
knowledge produced in
other disciplines such as critical race
theory black studies sociology
and in my case performance studies and
dense studies is a move
that is welcome in english studies
english has historically been
characterized as a discipline by
anti-disciplinary drives
at least in the departments where i have
had the good fortune to work
and in very recent years thus i have
personally found
english to be a good non-disciplining
discipline to operate from
but i do think that the future
developments of early modern critical
race studies require
expanding in transnational and
multilinguistic directions
taking the project in a complete
direction if you will
because the invention of whiteness in
the pre-modern era was a transnational
endeavor
so such expansion is in tune with the
transnational and diasporic dynamics
that have always been at the core of
black studies
and i believe that the study of race
along those lines can help early modern
english studies move
past the anglocentrism that has for so
long
limited their purview and potential
thank you
um and yate thank you to the organizers
for convening this important dialogue
um for my indigenous colleagues who are
tuning in
i will also introduce myself as a dna
my so-called interracial heritage is
revealed in the introduction of my four
dna clans my mother's clan
is followed by my non-native father of
mexican and german american ancestry
but unlike euro-american categories of
racial and ethnic classification
dna and indigenous epistemologies are
shared in order to find connection
identify a means of relation and also
responsibility to each other
rather than social difference it is
perhaps of this knowledge so ingrained
in my identity formation
living in in between my mother's birth
home on the navajo nation
and the off reservation places that she
carried me that curiosities of my own
racialized difference
took hold for many bipark scholars our
own histories and vulnerabilities are
what drives the work that we do
and also what makes it so difficult
because our bodies
our skin and our histories can also
become uncomfortable points of critical
interrogation
increasingly i'm finding strength in
this radical vulnerability
as a way of reckoning my own place in
the trajectory of historically white
academic spaces
the role that our disciplinary founders
and quotes here have played in shaping
these discourses and how this knowledge
can be employed in our pedagogy
activism and public engagements to
confront structures of racism
white supremacy and settler colonial
violence
so i present this intimate portrait as
an invitation for us to explore the
differential ways
that race is invoked in discussions of
blackness and indigeneity
in asian studies and what connections
might be forged between our overlapping
and unique struggles
these concerns of course are by no means
new
in the discipline of anthropology in
which i was trained for instance
scholars like lee baker have
interrogated how categories of culture
were deployed to the study the so-called
disappearing
indians by early american ethnologists
while categories of race were used by
early sociologists to study african
americans
the problems of classification and
differentiation are not only a
disciplinary one
but also a trademark of colonial and
imperial power
consider now the category of indian
the fallacy of the title references a
gross navigational error by the mass
murderer christopher columbus
as documented in his own journals the
transatlantic voyage of columbus set in
motion centuries of european
colonization in the americas
under his leadership the indigenous
population of hispaniola now haiti in
the dominican republic
estimated between 500 000 to 1 million
people in 1492
plummeted to 60 000 within a single
generation
following this violent encounter
european philosophers and theologians
began to consider the morality and
humanity
of the native inhabitants that they
quote discovered
did they have souls did they possess
reason could they be governed
contrary to the assumption that conquest
was justified through the construction
of radical alterity
colonization under the spanish empire
legitimized through the christian logic
of divine hierarchical power
made the indian into a rational and
legible subject
in order to be governable on the other
hand as
argued by scholars such as stuart banner
the british were less concerned about
soul matter or capacity for rationality
within a humanistic tradition
rather the colonization of north america
required
an initial initial recognition of
indigenous property ownership
to the extent that if the english wanted
indian land then they would have to
purchase it
the recognition of native property it
seems was only in the moment
in the sale transaction
this larger notion of political
recognition engaged by
scholars such as audra simpson glenn
coulthard beth povinelli
and property is central to ongoing
political debates over indigenous
sovereignty and their right to existence
in settler colonial states of australia
new zealand canada and the united states
today
therefore to reckon with the violence of
racial classification is also to
confront the persistent structures of
whiteness
which as aboriginal scholar eileen
morton robertson argues
is rooted within logics of possession
whether it be owning property being
property
or becoming property less these ideas
around property and possession form the
basis of a settler and a white national
identity
an identity that many native scholars
have argued is also predicated on the
dispossession of indigenous land
the dilution of indigenous blood and
identity through blood quantum politics
as critically explored by lakota scholar
kim talbear
and osage scholar gene dennison
and the erasure of limitations of
indigenous sovereignty in federal indian
policy
so to bring us back to the title of our
panel today racial reckonings
i'd like to for all of us to consider
the tangible ways we can build upon
existing race conversations to imagine
how we might translate
these disciplinary and historical
differences into greater solidarity
around movements for reparations and
land acknowledgements in our respective
campuses
this is by no means an end goal but
rather one way to demand a radically
different relationship of universities
with their histories and those they
serve
thank
thank you everyone those were phenomenal
opening comments with so much depth and
complexity um usually i have lots of
synthetic questions i have a couple
because i'm still digesting that was
amazing
i want to open if you don't mind with a
very broad
question that i think most of you if not
all of you
sort of touched indirectly on
um in in your comments at one point or
another
um and so let me ask the question and
then i'll see if i can remind the
audience of a few of the examples of
when it was when it came up
um so my sort of broad sort of
intentionally a little bit provocative
question is
um do you think the disciplinary
structures
that we are grappling with are capable
of um being a part of the
transformations
being a productive part of the
transformations that your collective
work
is speaking to right that is to say
um are are they going to be blown up
matt sort of has a
an image that they're going to
disintegrate i'm looking forward to
seeing that
um um you know rod talked a bit about
right the the ways in which there's an
institutional and epistemological
challenge which implies
right that things are going to have to
be dramatically changed
um you know marcy's talking about
the role of this kind of the art
bringing these objects
into places that are colonial but also
transforming that relationship
as three quick examples but you know
are these institutions really capable of
this you know
i mean i guess i want to push a few of
you if you're interested in taking the
challenge
to sort of um
really explore that right i mean i
understand what we're doing in relation
to these institutions but
when we're in our relative cubbies it
doesn't seem like a lot of disruptions
happening when we're together in a
cohort
there seems like a lot of disruption of
amazing scholars
but there's a lot of people doing this
work in in the way that we would be
challenged
by so i'm just throwing it open um
i don't know anyone i'm open to anyone i
i think i mentioned marcy matt and rod
so maybe one of you could start us off
and then
everyone is open to engage
okay well maybe i'll go um thanks rod
pleasure um you know i think it's
difficult
for every
field you know within a university
because
especially the disciplines i mean even
the category the discipline
you know is in and of itself it means a
resistance
to um change innovation
shifts blah blah blah and it's not as if
the inner disciplines
are immune from that because
you know they're also subject to those
logics at the same time
um even with the problems of the
interdisciplinary fields
i would put my money on the inner
disciplines over the disciplines
in terms of the kinds of uh
changes that you're talking about right
if you look
at where are the
minoritized faculty hired located
students under-represented students in
terms of majors
located uh it's in the interdisciplines
i mean i'll never forget
a conference that i was symposium that i
went to
years ago i think like in 2011 um
at ucla between the ucla center for the
study of women
and nyu's counterpart they had a joint
conference and kathleen mchugh
who was the director
of the center at ucla had a slide up
you know saying showing where all of the
underrepresented faculty
were you know in the university and
they were all in the inner disciplines
so the question was if we took away the
inner disciplines what would then happen
to those faculty members
they would be gone okay and so
if you think about that's one example if
you think about
another example you know um
i'm a bit biased here but i also think
it's true the american studies
association
right and all of these sort of epistemic
revolutions
that field has gone through you know
from
you know the immediate end of world war
ii
in terms of american studies really
being an
alibi for the us during the cold war
period
but also then being changed by
uh the social movements around race and
gender and then being changed again
by uh the critique of u.s empire
and globalization you know thinking here
of that culture of u.s imperialism
um book from amy kaplan and don pease
that anthology but then changed again in
terms of post-nationalist american
studies
then changing again because of uh
the work of scholars and disability
studies
in queer studies and trans studies in
indigenous studies
you know so we can actually
point to um
[Music]
instances in which the interdisciplines
have uh been
you know more ready to enact the kind of
changes that you're talking about
there are still problems you know i
don't want to
lose sight of that but in terms of um
the kinds of transformations both
epistemic and social
the end of this was the care of the day
i mean they carry that history
okay all right so long live the
interdisciplines
long-lived in the disciplines matt did
you want to jump in or marcy or
um i'll i'll buy marcy some time um
i i to you know i think trisha answer
your question directly
um i don't i think it's a question of
whether the discipline should survive
whether the whether the humanity should
survive as they are
uh in order to in order to center racial
justice or
or just race in the humanities and i
don't think they should i don't think
they can
um i think that's this is the other side
of the second paragraph after raj's
paragraph
uh about the the value of the
interdisciplines is that the disciplines
themselves are inherently conservative
uh in hegemonic and and that we we stand
to have to fight department by
department
field by field subfield by subfield in
order to advance
interests to get one higher one faculty
member one course taught
and that that struggle will outlive us
um there's you know we can't we can't
win that struggle
so it's it is true that in some
institutions so much of this is
university by university like i'm
thinking about my own history department
at rutgers which i much
beloved but which uh centered black
women's history from the moment i got
there and
was utterly formative to me but most
history departments as you know even
within the u.s
field have subdivisions that mitigate
and
constrain any department from actually
hiring or focusing on race
right yeah it's a very effective
mechanism that's what i'm really trying
to get at is that despite these
incredible interventions
right there's been just a capacity to
reproduce itself in all of its
narrowness but um let me let marcy uh
jump in marcy yeah uh thank you
um so yeah sitting here
trying to think about your question
all the only word that was going through
my head
was like no like it's it's
um they're not capable museums are not
capable
um art history you know for all for all
the reasons
we've been kind of delineating
um and as i tried to kind of point out
in my presentation it's just like this
paradox that i have been
grappling with and doing this work where
um you know it really started when
i was teaching this class on asian
american art when i first got to
stanford in 2016 and i just realized how
much of this work was
people's homes you know um in their
garages
like these are works that have material
lives um you know they
endure in time i mean ruth asawa called
those masks moments of stop time which
is
on one hand i think something that makes
them so
um powerful um
and on the other hand is what makes them
fetish objects right um and and people
want to desire them so much and so
like that contradiction seems to me to
be built
like directly into the character of an
art object itself
you know and of course there are like
kind of contemporary practices that
attempt to critique and deconstruct this
but like
you know i'm we're talking about um an
entire kind of history
of work um and so i think that you know
um i think that for now
all i've been trying to do is um in some
ways tolerate that paradox
and and know
that
this work you know the bernice thing
that i showed you um
part of the condition of taking it was
um it was damaged in a fire
um and were you know the museum has the
resources to restore it
um and and she tried to it was important
from 65 and she tried to restore it at
the end of her life
and before she passed and so like um you
know
those moments i know are important
but ultimately i think the accretion
if we're really trying to move towards
like racial justice
is that they will destroy the
institutions that they're in
right yeah yeah yeah this is one of the
tensions okay i have one more
and then i'm gonna move to our audience
questions i just want to encourage
people who are listening
to place their questions in the q a and
we'll we'll do our best to get to them
uh one more thing uh and i'm gonna i'm
gonna ask theresa and noemi to sort of
begin but everyone's welcome as
to jump in and that is this really
interesting tension
between um the the expression of the
a number of you used to to the the
influence of
racial analysis to force a change in the
objects
and that by changing the objects we are
in the process
of of doing some kind of important
racially transformational work noemi you
mentioned this
teresa i think you said something along
these lines
uh and and uh by interesting contrast i
think rod you were the only one to talk
about
sort of new subjects in the university
coming into into place
so i'm i'm um and then of course matt
you the objects
that uh dana brings back right are
extremely
important for for her survival so
i'm interested in this tension around
objects the importance of
of using objects but of course the
objectification the fact that
racial subjects are in fact the original
objects
um and what to do with that tension
um and just talk a little bit more about
you know
what what this changing of objects means
in the discipline
and whether or not it must be
accompanied by a change in subjects
uh and and how those things might fit
together
teresa do you want to go first
i'm happy if you prefer
yeah i guess um i might come back to
this after you again
um as the sole social scientist here
i might be coming at this question a
little bit differently
maybe i'll just answer this by way of
explaining my
own desire or impulse to even go into
anthropology
as many of you may know i mean
anthropology was a discipline that
relied
extensively upon the study of others of
native americans of
our bones um our our literal bodies
right and this
um you know also filled museum
collections some early ethnological
collection so
you know my interest was really around
the material culture
and actual objects right so my initial
um desire to go into anthropology was
through museum anthropology
i i wanted to be in these museum spaces
to help try
to try to curate this history in a more
appropriate way
in a way that was more respectful to
my ancestors and our relatives that are
literally still in these museum
collections
and like all of you that have expressed
you know these um this caution around
the
the potential for institutional change
you know i felt that very strongly
actually with museums and it actually
was part of the the reason why
um i've even though i continued to do
museum work and i continued to
guest curate for exhibitions
i still found potential in education
itself so this is why i've gone
through this route of doing research and
education
rather than going the route of becoming
a curator that being said
you know there's still um a lot to be
changed within anthropology
um you know at the university of chicago
i'm
one of just a few native faculty who
have ever existed
you know um and there is no existing
native studies program
um you know when i was hired and when i
accepted
um you know it was under condition that
there would be
you know this native studies program in
formation so i'm still
i know there's these conversations
happening and there's there's definitely
um some movement but i know that this
will take time institutional change
takes time
um so for myself where i
i see um maybe the potential for change
and which i think
all of us maybe should be pushing back
against um across each of our
disciplines is just the single author
model like that's something that is
has become increasingly bothersome to me
that i didn't really question at all as
a graduate student
um and i've had these conversations with
a lot of other folks so now that i'm in
my postdoc
i've found myself actually increasingly
collaborating with people in other
disciplines um
in the sciences you know in public
health
or folks who are working in hydrology
like things i didn't really imagine
before but it was because
the problems that i'm confronting in my
research i think necessitates
um people who are doing that like on the
ground work
and i can bring like a historical or a
political sort of analysis to that sort
of work
and i work on environmental
contamination and indigenous sovereignty
in the southwest um
so these these are kind of some of my um
concerns that i've been you know
struggling with over the past year or
two
is i'm you know now charting this new
trajectory of my research
and obviously covid has thrown a lot of
my previous plans
um you know a jar a bit um
but yeah i would love to hear from the
rest of you about
what not just within our own disciplines
and departments but you know the larger
structures of academia and how
how we can imagine change
or or ways to um you know
push back on on these structures that
have been you know um
confining to us
yeah to so i i'm going to answer um
your question trisha about subjects
versus objects although there's no
verses
really but just i wanted to go back
first to the question about disciplines
can can the disciplines help can they
make it are they capable
um i will say that i personally have
very little
interest in disciplinarity or
disciplines or the survival or
capabilities of discipline
i got my phd in theater from a
department of english and comparative
literature
and i was working mostly on spanish and
french within that structure
so i think it's particularly the case
for me but it's the case of all of us
that we are not working in a discipline
we're all working within
a venn diagram of multiple disciplines
right
um and so i would just say that i am
very opportunistic about this i don't
have
faith in the disciplines but i also am
very willing to mobilize them
strategically
and for instance right now i'm teaching
a course called black shakespeare
and i am very willing very ready to
harness
all the disciplinary affordances of
english you know studying the hyper
canonical figure of shakespeare
if it allows me to get students to think
about race critically to bring into the
room all the founders of the field
and and thinkers in black studies um and
i think a number of
of us have been doing that i'm thinking
about you know the um
the involvement of major institutions
like the shakespeare association of
america which has been a force
of transformation in the field over the
last couple of years
so i don't you know i don't want to
sound too naive here
i think i'm you know i'm uh and i'm in
line with everybody here but
um i i am very willing to be
opportunistic as far as disciplines are
concerned
um to make change happen but concerning
the objects versus
uh subject difference perhaps i i wasn't
clear i was actually um
trying to suggest that um this
this um involvement of my field in
building a pipeline to diversify the the
professor at
means that we are very acutely painfully
acutely aware
of the fact that we need new subjects
doing this work as i was mentioning
there are less than 20
faculty members who are black
shakespeareans in this country
right every department every every every
english major is going to take a
shakespeare course at some point
20 professors are black doing this work
um so we are very aware of it
but the to clarify what i meant when i
said
new objects i don't mean that the
objects themselves are changing
i mean that if you bring new subjects to
work on them they will see new things
because the way we read the world is is
positioned
and conditional upon our own
positionality right
so if you uh get a scholar like me for
instance who lives in a black body
and is used to speaking with an accent
then the question
of the black accents in the audi modern
repertoire is going to be something that
they see
in place that other scholars had not
seen before so i think
actually that the the production of new
objects of knowledge
and new subjects those are actually uh
completely embedded they work together
and this is this is the only way really
to to say new
exciting things about a figure like
shakespeare at this point
marcy your matter rod any
things emerge from this do you want why
anna
yeah go ahead matt i just i just want to
say
um what uh noemie and teresa were saying
is so totally uh and devastatingly
apparent
that if you don't diversify the faculty
at the same time that you diversify the
the material we study you end up with
the story of the move family
and the story of penn and princeton
which is currently all over the news um
which is a repeat of the story that
theresa started with ways in which
um you know the the pain of
minoritized subjects becomes the object
of established disciplines
uh is is a is just too familiar and uh
can't be repeated
you know what i'll add that um
you know this is social movement wisdom
you know in terms
of the link between
um the constitution of
the object and the simultaneous
introduction of new subjects you know if
you think about
you know for instance what angela davis
says in
that documentary herbert's hippopotamus
about
herbert marcuza at uc san diego
she's talking about the lumumba zapata
movement um in 1969 where the university
says we're going to have a new college
it's going to be called third college
and she says
no my comrades and i have decided it
will be called lumumba zapata college
it will not be called third college and
we had a curriculum
right so they took over the college
with the uh intention of producing
and introducing new subjects peoples
communities
into the college and they had a
curriculum right
so that the introduction of
these folks necessarily meant you know
um an epistemic shift
that there had to be a new way of
understanding
the world the us race
colonialism the legacies of colonialism
and we see that kind of thing repeated
for instance at um the open admissions
movement
at city college that the introduction in
that context of african-americans
and puerto rican students you know
anybody who wanted to be in could get in
was the idea
they also produced you know a new
curriculum and had a vision
for school the same thing for san
francisco state so the link between
um the constitution of epistemic objects
and the production of new subjects
that's social movement
wisdom yeah yeah marxie
uh um so you mentioned san francisco
state rod um
you know actually i was doing some
work with uh with an artist actually who
um
has made work about um the third world
liberation front and he
pulled out an archival document he had
in his studio because he was like
hanging out with everyone um
and one of the things on the third world
curriculum
like in 68 was asia it was an asian
american art course
um and so so there's that um but you
know i just want to say i agree with um
what everyone has said of course about
um
new subjects and new objects being kind
of entwined um
the you know i when i first drafted my
talks was way too long
my remarks were way too long but i had
this story about like which i'm sure all
of us have similar stories which is like
you know like in 2014 so this was like
seven years ago and i know it was the
state because
it was um it was around the time of
ferguson
um i went to someone um
on faculty at the institute of fine arts
at nyu where i was getting my phd in art
history
there was no one on my committee or not
my advisor
and told him i wanted to work on race
and asian american
things and he told me that i should work
on jewishness um because
art historians are jewish and so they'll
be more sympathetic to my topic
you know it's like seven years ago um
and i think that all of the assumptions
um about the relationship of subjects
and objects
is is in that statement
yeah you say seven years ago with
you know much of that meant it was a
long time ago it was just yesterday
and that's how horrible the thought is i
have i have no idea
honestly but um it almost feels like you
know in 1958 yeah
yeah yeah yeah time flies and then it
doesn't move at all
yeah and so that's just um it's just to
say that
art history is so conservative
um and has been for such a long time
you know it's sometimes even really hard
to explain this to my friends in english
they're like you know there's a subfield
of asian american studies there's no
asian american literature that subfield
doesn't exist in art history
and i think the other thing about like
new objects in the pipeline you know
something that um
teresa mentioned as well it's like i
talk about this with my friends of color
we're art historians all the time
um and we're like it's the privilege of
being able to work in a museum over the
summer
you know um and get that hands-on
experience with
objects and then you know which then
gives you connections to go into
fellowships and
so academia is actually really
interleaved
with a lot of um um like kind of funding
organizations that themselves still
are um yeah like
are still kind of guided by by capital
and so we
so there's a lot of um there's a lot of
work
to be done still right i mean and this
disconnects what you're saying marcy to
um a broader issue i'm going to just
throw it out there while it's on my mind
but i do want to
i started asking some audience questions
and there's a really good one to start
with
but you know there's this um this
realization that um
the work uh that has to be done is
really
you know the academic work is tethered
to structures of power
that that our departments disciplines
and even some of our interdisciplines
reinforced through a sense of hierarchy
about
what kinds of work matters how that work
is done
and who's going to evaluate the value of
that work
um and you know just you know i mean no
i may i agree that
you know english is is a little more
porous
but i'm you know i i wouldn't say that
the level of creative
you know integration and complexity that
you're doing
is pretty standard in english
departments so you know
you know we all have our that's the
problem with gathering you know creative
people who are pushing all these
boundaries because they're
like hey yeah there's look at us we're
here and i'm like yeah and then there's
like 40 million people standing over
there in the corner
in a in a straight disciplinary line so
anyway i won't go back to that because
that's my pet peeve but
let me this is a question for anyone who
wants to answer it
um but it's drawn on uh matt's uh
concept and part of what he said so i'm
going to read the question and
and give you all a chance to answer it
okay this person is asking the following
i'm
moved by dr guterrell's call for us to
prepare for a reckoning
that stands to be cataclysmic to the
academy
as we know it i want to ask the
roundtable what their
knives and their emergency packs
are given that this reckoning is not
just coming but
for graduate students post docs and
adjuncts among us
is already here what are the contingency
plans and alternative homes for
intellectual work that we should be
investing in
so there are two questions there i will
just ask that you take one
and that will just give us room for
other people to take another so one
is what are the um knives and emergency
packs
um for to prepare for the reckoning that
stands to be cataclysmic in the academy
that's question a so what's your you
know emergency pack flash
knife and the other is given that the
reckoning is basically here
what are the contingency plans and
alternative homes for intellectual work
that we should be investing in and this
kind of dovetails with what rod was
saying about having your own curriculum
right and as a possibility now where
that might be
we might have other locations but i will
open the floor to anyone who wants to
pick up
one or the other of those questions
well i'm happy to get us uh started with
the second question you know
plan b's what are some plan b's um i
think the plan b's are very compatible
with the plan a's to start with
but the my point is that i am thinking
um every every kind of work that will
allow the transformation that we're
trying to have happen in the plan a in
the academy
um every single form of work that will
enable that to radiate
right for instance we want uh students
to be
you know in my field already invested
having um having some interest in
working in pre-modern race studies
dealing with
race and shakespeare and how everything
is working it's already too late
usually when they arrive in college
level they already think that
shakespeare and
everything from that time period is not
for them so actually
investing heavily in the training of our
high school teachers and giving them the
tools to do some of that work
earlier on when it's still possible that
is really important
i'm also thinking about um the kind of
work that we see
partner institutions doing for instance
again i'm thinking
you know i think about what i know i'm
thinking about the institutions
that i'm working with i'm thinking of
the newbery library for instance
which is at the moment really invested
in animating quickly studies and is
trying to help
make that work visible so in 2023 raise
before race is coming to chicago
the newberry library is curating an
exhibition that will be opened
to everybody to the republic and to high
school students
in order to you know familiarize folks
with those questions
there are jobs there there are forms of
expertise that we are trained to provide
that we are trained to give to our own
students our graduate students
and that we don't you know have the time
or the bandwidth
to share with everybody so involving uh
the excellent students that we train you
know into that work so that they might
be able to
uh to share that knowledge as their
contingency plan
i think is something that should be on
the table
very helpful excellent way to get us
going anybody else want to
jump in on plan b or other intellectual
work
preparing for the reckoning contingency
alternative homes
well i'll just add a little bit to it to
what you were saying
um since i'm also in chicago and i'm i'm
doing projects with the newberry um
right now um i think a lot of my
public scholarship as i said you know my
i started in museum studies and
you know even though i didn't um go the
full curation route i've
i've maintained a foot in that world
because of its importance for public
education
because of the failure to prepare
students
um you know having any sort of um
understanding of native history
um usually in you know their um k
through 12 education and then once
um i get freshmen or sophomore students
and having to really
start from the very beginning with um
native history before i can
even get into more complicated ideas
around
sovereignty or land status or blood
quantum
i think one way to do that
is you know through through museums
because this is a place that a lot of
students will go and that is their first
introduction to what native people are
um you know as someone who also got my
degree at nyu
you know i'd go to the american museum
of natural history and you know it's
appalling um as most museums
of natural history are you know you
literally have all of the other people
of the world you know you have the
indigenous people you have africans you
have everyone
that is not white in a museum um on
display
next to um woolly mammoth
um so it's part of this this continuum
and hierarchy
um that um i think
you know children begin to to to
understand and naturalize um with that
being said
you know so the the field museum here in
chicago um
also has a really bad history you know
as early its earliest collections are
through the 1893 you know world's fair
um and they also until recently had pre
you know old
native american displays but for the
past two years
um the institution has undertaken this
new initiative to redesign their native
american galleries and to invite
native scholars curators to help with
the
this new formation so i was invited to
be a guest curator on some of the cases
and i've been working on this for the
past
year and this is really um you know
there's been some challenges along the
way i won't lie
but having the opportunity to actually
help guide
the voice and interpretation of what is
going to be on display now for the next
who you know however a dozen 20 years um
like that to me is possibly more
impactful than
any like journal article that i'm
writing right now in terms of audience
reach
um and you know those those sorts of
um things um you know not aren't
necessarily the first thing
that that one considers for their you
know their ten year file
but for me what's important is is having
having my scholarship reach places
that's not behind a pay wall
um so just building off of you know what
all of you are saying is like these
these are like tangible ways that we can
um you know try to shift discourses and
to to educate people in ways that
perhaps you know aren't aren't
necessarily you know the traditional
ways that we've been taught
um so yeah i think museum institutions
is one way to go about that change
um i can jump in you know um
so for me this answer like a and b are
related you know um this past year
i have you know a lot of friends who are
faculty members of color especially
junior faculty
um and i don't think i've talked to a
single
one of them without the topic of leaving
the academy coming up
um i think all of us are just like
what do we do you know and how is our
labor being used
um and actually
that might be the answer which is
not necessarily leaving but being
willing to leave
you know um and realizing that um
well and one being in conversation with
people you know
um so being in community with people who
think who
are engaging with similar things
but two like um you know i'd say like my
toolkit is psychoanalysis
because i've really had to think very
hard this year about my own attachments
um my continued attachments to whiteness
like structures of whiteness
um and structures of legitimacy
and i really think that
and of course you know that work is
forever incomplete
right but um i really think that
thinking about my own attachments
and being willing to see outside of the
structure
and realize that like
i am a whole person without it
is to me the first step in trying to
rethink what i need to rethink
yeah i think there have to be a number
of different ways to approach this and i
and i think we need all of these kinds
of
modes i i for one you know trisha you
know
as well as i do that giving up on the
institution
um all of us giving up on the
institution at once
would be destructive and catastrophic in
the ways that i'm
describing and in fact higher education
is one of the least innovative
industries or business models if you
think about it we've seen very few new
university startups
and it's amazing how durable these
brands are
and how resistant they are to to
destruction
um we haven't seen the university
collapses that we thought we were going
to see
at the start of this pandemic and we're
not likely to
so one thing i would suggest is that you
know new
new ways of thinking about the
institution could be
materialized in front of us and one one
exit strategy for us all would be to
think about
whether the brands we attach ourselves
to brown yale
university of chicago and stanford are
the brands we want to be attached to
whether whether we want to be attached
to a different kind of community and a
different
kind of institution that we might make
anew
at the same time like i also know that
like
sometimes the difference between hiring
a person at brown is the difference
between
one last email in the middle of the
night one last cup of coffee one last
meeting with the dean one last try
and you can't you can't stop that right
so as a senior faculty member i can't
stop that labor
uh because that as uh that could be the
difference between so
the right person getting the job and the
wrong person getting the job right and
that could have a 40-year
catastrophic you know impact
yeah sorry i didn't mean to interrupt i
just couldn't i couldn't help but
draw out the the consequences right
that's what my my my kid is definitely
gonna have coffee and candy in it
for uh for sort of late night emails and
yeah
yeah your kids are lucky that you're so
disciplined they get treated um
rod did you want to jump in here
um well let's see maybe i'll have some
fun with
a um what would i bring with me
um honestly
i would bring with me
a pen and a paper and a big
note board for the students you know
um you know i
one of the reasons i love that passage
from dera da
is that you know in addition to saying
that the imagining of the institution or
the reimagining of the institution is
immediate
to what we do it's also very simple
you know it means that okay let me start
writing
you know or let me start uh crafting
this course and in that moment
you know a new socialist a new community
can be brought into being so
i mean at the end of the day i joke with
my students sometimes you know
being from rural georgia and having very
good
uh i think black teachers you know who
are veterans of segregated
teaching that at the end of the day i am
that old negro
intellectual you give me you know a pen
and a paper and let me teach
let me write and i can do something
yeah yeah give me the material just give
me the material
and you know let me do my job and um
you know something's going to happen
right right so i mean that's interesting
because
um you know
a lot of your comments as a panel were a
combination of
sort of taking a certain kind of for
grantedness of what rod just emphasized
which is that
you're bringing to these objects
bringing to these museums
bringing to various departments bringing
to visual culture and
and our history a whole set of
frameworks a tradition of critique a
tradition of
transformation and refusal that uh
is part of the process i just want to
you know put that
on the extreme rod was just saying i
know where i'm coming from just give me
some paper
but the paper has to be in the right
hands right the paper in the pen
um and so all of you are are actually
articulating this and in that sense i'd
say
you know the knives and emergency packs
are
not literal right they're really the way
we do what we do
not the object that we do it with so
whether it's a knife or an emergency
pack it doesn't actually matter
it's really about the form of intensive
critique and refusal
to some degree um so um so before we
close i just want to give you all an
opportunity first of all to ask each
other any questions to
talk about things that i unfortunately
stepped over that i shouldn't have or
things that have come to your mind that
you want to you want to leave us with
you know in the form of closing comments
because by the time we
get to you all speaking you know it'll
probably be a little bit past 4 30.
um so i'm just going to leave the floor
open and if you don't
have anything as other than closing
comments just offer some closing
comments about
you know how we can how we can really
pursue this kind of
you know intervention that we want that
we want to see
can i make a quick quick comment getting
back to something matt
uh said earlier when you were talking
matt about the
um the english discipline and the fact
that
it's um it's been limited by its
inability to shed
stupid periodization or division on the
basis of language which
i resent very deeply so i'm i'm on board
with you there
uh but i just you also mentioned
something very interesting which is that
um
medieval studies in particular have
become you know the
the knowledge the extraordinary body of
knowledge has been produced
over decades uh in in medieval studies
has sadly become the bedrock of a lot of
white supremacist
um propaganda these days absolutely true
i just want to point out that we're
fighting back right we're fighting back
and um raised before race i'll keep
mentioning it uh was based upon the idea
of bringing together
medievalists who don't yet have a very
strong tradition of working with
critical race theory
bringing them together with early
modernists who have been doing that
since the 90s
and the next iteration of the conference
at brandeis next week
is going to actually bring in
classicists so we're going back
further and further dealing with race
before race but um
the idea is that precisely we cannot let
that happen we cannot
let the um all the cultural artifacts
produce during those
um those time periods become fodder for
that nonsense
uh and so that's that i think is what
actually makes
our work meaningful yeah let me say two
quick things can you repeat the brandeis
conference because there were people
asking about it in the chat
and i didn't want to interrupt so or if
you could put it in the chat
i'm going to drop that i think i dropped
the link earlier but i will redo it i
will drop the the link in the chat again
it's raised before race at brandeis
uh university and it starts next week
great
yeah and just to really comment on this
so important observation you made that
we think of social justice and racial
intervention
being the beginning of a conversation
about racial intervention when in fact
the disciplines
as colonial forms of ideology formation
were
actually the first racial
interventionist right and they're
they're coming back strong but anyway
i'll leave that alone but i just thought
that was super important anybody else um
in closing or any other thoughts you
know i was just going to say to noemi's
comments i remember how thrilling it was
when i was an undergraduate at howard in
1990 to discover
that folks like martin bernal were
intervening
in um the field of classics and then
later on when i was
a grad student at
uc san diego taking a course a feminist
theory course
with paige dubois you know um
and her interventions uh via marxism
and feminism and post-colonial studies
and psychoanalysis
in classics and you know just seeing the
ways
in which both at howard and at ucsd's
literature department
that those interventions became the
sites
for the introduction of new
feminist subjects new black subjects in
those fields you know it was really
really an exciting
thing to witness and also to repeat
i mean i i would want to return to one
of the things i said in my opening
remarks which is that in a way
i really do feel enveloped
in such an abundance of interesting work
interesting relevant just
and righteous work on race that falls
within the humanities
in a way that i that i didn't feel when
i was a graduate student that the sheer
volume of material that um that lands on
my desk or arrives on my computer screen
or shows up on my television
is just extraordinary and there there
has to be
this is worth um fighting for and it's
worth trying to center
to take all of that material worth
trying to center in these medieval
institutions we inhabit
uh here so i want us to sort of think
about the ways in which
we can bring all of that that joyful
abundance
and put it at the center of these places
again even if that means breaking them a
little bit
or a lot yeah yeah
excellent thank you teresa or marcy or
any closing thoughts
um yeah i guess
maybe just that um
every single time i return to one of the
works
you know one of the one of the works of
art um
that
you know i've been really spent the last
the
my time at stanford looking at it always
always um exceeds the capacity of any
single discourse to capture it
all right theresa um
well i just want to say thank you to
everyone for having me here
um i want to give a shout out to my
colleague at uchicago sarah johnson
um we were actually awarded some melon
funding for the next academic year so
we're going to be
starting this project called tracing
relations blackness and indigeneity in
the americas and this is inspired by
um you know she's she's in english in
black studies and i'm coming from
anthropology and native studies and i
think
both of us have come to the space of
vulnerability together
um you know there's so much that i have
yet to to learn
in reading of black studies as someone
who's mostly been reading in native
studies and
and her vice versa um
so for anyone from uchicago who's
watching um
just be on a lookout because we're going
to be having uh reading groups
and film screenings next year convened
around this orienting theme of
relationality that we find
really important to both of those
disciplines and discourses but i feel
like
some of the discussions we've been
having today has actually given me a lot
of new ideas for how we can move forward
on that
we do plan to make a website for this
and maybe we'll have some
virtual component that we can continue
um with the same group of people
um but we don't have that yet so i just
want to say thank you for for giving me
the opportunity
to to think further on this project yes
yes indeed and i feel the same way and
i'm sure my
director colleagues jennifer and uh
riley and
steve and um am i missing anybody
uh no there's four of us i always have
to count one two three four um
our our i've been super inspired by
listening to all of you here
really thinks in such rich ways um about
the problems the solutions the
impossibilities the places to both hide
out
and to be visible um and uh and
and the role of just such creative
thinking which i think has been so
important here so i'm
really inspired and i'm hoping our grant
will will benefit from and take up a
number of the things that we've been
doing here so
thank you so much all of you for for
being a part of this inaugural what we
hope maybe an annual conference on
racial reckoning because we want to keep
opening up the space let us know what
you're working on stay in touch and
thank those of you who showed up in the
audience and asked great questions and
and hung out with us this afternoon and
we will see you again there's a
an event tomorrow around at the same
time i believe it's the same link for
sign up but
um i'm sure you can find that how you
found this and maybe they'll put it in
the chat
thank you all very much for coming and
thanks again to the fine panelists for
for being really uh terrific thanks very
much everybody good night